Leon: The Chechen dictator, Ramzan Kadyrov,
posted a surveillance-like video where you
and another opposition leader looked like
being in crosshairs.
Now, given that your friend and colleague,
Boris Nemtsov, was killed last year, and given
that you were nearly poisoned to death, what
do you think of this instance of harassment?
Vladimir: Given Mr. Kadyrov's background and
reputation, both Mikhail Kasyanov and I consider
this video to be a direct threat, to be direct
and public incitement to murder, and in fact
we have already submitted an official request
for a criminal probe into this posting, this
publication.
In fact, in the last few weeks, we have seen
how serious of what seem to be coordinated
attacks and threats issued by Mr. Kadyrov
himself as well as his close henchmen against
Kremlin opponents, against Russian opposition
leaders.
And frankly, I think this whole series of
events is a direct result of the brazen impunity
that has surrounded the assassination of our
friend, my friend, Russian opposition leader
Boris Nemtsov, who was gunned down 200 yards
away from the Kremlin nearly a year ago in
February 2015.
Despite the fact that traces of this crime
evidently lead to Grozny or at least through
Grozny...
Leon: The capital of Chechnya.
Vladimir: Absolutely.
Or at least through the capital of Chechnya.
And despite the fact that those arrested on
suspicion of murdering Boris were serving
members of the Interior Ministry of the Russian
Federation in Chechnya.
Leon: Victorian Guard, I would think.
Vladimir: Absolutely.
Despite the fact that Mr. Kadyrov publicly
called the man accused of killing Boris Nemtsov
to be called a true patriot, and despite the
numerous requests by the lawyers representing
Boris Nemtsov's children to question Mr. Kadyrov
regarding this case, he wasn't questioned
even formally by the investigators.
We hear no criticism of him or his actions
or his public threats from the Kremlin, in
fact we hear the opposite.
We hear, we continue to hear laudatory statements
from the top Russian leadership with regard
to Mr. Kadyrov.
But on the substance of your question, yes,
we know that it's a dangerous location to
be in opposition to Vladimir Putin's regime.
We have seen too many confirmations of that
already.
So we know the risks, we understand the risks.
But frankly I think, we, those who view the
future of Russia differently from what the
present regime does, we have no right to stand
down or to give up or to run away because
it's our country and we have to fight for
it.